there is no reason to believe that our
universe
is unique
it is quite possible that just as our
universe was created many universes were
also created
that is the case then we live not in a
single universe but in a vast collection
of universes that physicists refer to as
the Multiverse we can think of those as
Island universes each with its own
quirks maybe even each with its own laws
of physics
for example there could be one of these
other universes where gravity is a
hundred times stronger than it is in our
universe
it could somehow prove conclusively the
existence of multiple universes of the
Multiverse that would be a genuine
intellectual Revolution a complete
change in a cosmic thinking